it's so interesting to me that you know
the far right wingers they seem to be so
skeptical of everything media
journalists everything is fake news
and yet if you put it in a meme
it's it's like it came from god himself
i i don't understand it
and i saw this that last week on my feed
there ricky schroeder remember him from
silver spoons he's now he's now a very
hard right winger he put this up a
picture of john f kennedy with the quote
there's a plot in this country to
enslave every man woman and child before
i leave this high and noble office i
intend to expose this plot
of course kennedy never said that
and yet they believe it and we found
some other ricky trump
[Music]
schroeder memes would you like to see
some of the oh this guy
uh look at this one without a strong
southern border one day will awaken to
the sound of a million car horns playing
la cucaracha abraham lincoln
did not say that
um
we're only one generation away from men
being forced to turn their pees into
wee-wees john adams not true
um
i've been sleeping on my pillows for
some time i love them use the promo code
rip van buren to receive peppers off
your next letter martin van buren
that's ridiculous
[Applause]
jews will not replace us george
washington did not say it
uh the greatest mistake hitler made was
to expel the very physicists who could
have built him a space laser albert no
no
uh donald trump is not just an american
treasure he's also a friend frederick
douglass did not say that
uh i pray to me that they never take
away the right to say merry christmas
jesus christ did not say that
um
i'm not bald this is alopecia benjamin
franklin
and
no matter what anyone says after about
me after i die remember i'm not black
and i definitely can't rap alexander
hamilton
never got a dinner
you